hey leute was gedacht und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen video ich habe
natürlich ist gut ich habe ja bereits
angekündigt immer wenn ich jetzt
irgendwo bin werde ich hier auch sachen
bestellen sachen testen und heute machen
wir direkt weiter in düsseldorf in ihr
nämlich gerade im hotel und ich dachte
mir ich nutze die möglichkeit um einfach
mal die drei besten burger ihr wisst ja
ich liebe bürger hier in düsseldorf zu
testen den ersten habe ich gestern
bereits getestet aber nicht auch
hingegangen das werden wir auch am
anfang einmal sehen und den zweiten und
dritten werde ich dann jetzt noch
bestellen und testen dafür ich würde ich
mal in köln ich kenne mich nicht mehr so
aus aber es gibt neue apps und zwar über
aids und wollt damals als ich diese
ganzen bestell videos gemacht habe gab
es diese apps nicht da gab es den libero
und lieferando das war es eigentlich
deswegen umso leiser der erste war der
beste von google bewertung her der
zweite wird der beste aufwärts und der
dritte wird der beste auf wollte dann
haben wir die drei besten burger in
düsseldorf als erstes haben wir den
bürger laden bob und max kottmann
leistungs aussieht also bin ich muss
sagen ich war direkt überzeugt und der
war zum glück gar nicht so weit von dem
hotel hier da sind wir gestern hinter
step und haben da mal die bürger
probiert wirklich nur richtig gute
bewertungen fünf sterne fünf sterne fünf
sterne mega bürger auch legale
alternativen tolles ambiente und nettes
personal definitiv wieder ich liebe die
bürger hier so lecker und saftig ihr
müsst ja im burger bestellen definitiv
empfehlenswert man muss aber vorher
reservieren nicht haben wir echt glück
gehabt und ob mir das ganze gefallen hat
dass hier sehr viel spaß bei den ersten
alex iburger test nach sehr langer zeit
so leute was geht ich bin jetzt hier in
düsseldorf unterwegs und wir testen
jetzt hans im glück den besten burger
düsseldorf nein aber hier um die ecke
ist wohl ein richtig richtig lag
herberger das hotel war jetzt nicht weit
von hier und den säcken weiter aus
gespannt da ist es schon oder war es das
danke fürs handy aussehen weil mein
handy ist mal wieder zerbrochen aber
marie hat mir ihr tolles handy zur
verfügung gestellt ist dass das hier das
war das dann leider kann ohne druck da
kinder kein platz
gute aussicht endlich mal wieder bürger
live ist so wird nehmen wir denn heute
läuft es wieder klassik mit neun monate
greifen echten englischen keller und
dazu eine classic freis mit einer
ansonsten gibt es auch in der burger
auswahl auch andere bürger wie zb mit
saftigen rechte laufenden französischen
ziegenkäse karamellisierten bieren und
roter zwiebel konfitüre alter wird der
laden ist auf jeden fall sehr gut
besucht wir haben aber noch glück gehabt
und ein platz ergattert aber sie mussten
zehn minuten auf die karten warten
wir sind auf jeden fall ist es ein
malkurs reinschreiben was man
isst
was die ich 30 bin urteil
gut
und so sind wir doch alle glücklich wenn
du glücklich bist leute ich habe
übrigens einen veganen bürgern gut mit
dem veganen live nachgemachten partien
eigentlich sah wo carlo creme glaub ich
hab dir aber gab noch nicht gesehen
deswegen ist also fleisch 1 august beim
supermarkt in echt überzeugt dass
mensdorff sondern gouda glaube ich
[Musik]
also das hätte ich nicht gedacht ist er
so gut ist
[Musik]
so sieht der von innen heraus
auch die trüffel meinung hier absolut
zur neuen funktionen dieses super lecker
ich muss hier nachträglich noch mal
sagen der bürger war echt unfassbar
lecker von mir gibt's 9,2 von zehn
sternen das fleisch hatte eine super
qualität hat alles super frisch
geschmeckt und auch die bands waren 1a
also dass auf jeden fall der beste
bürger die nicht jeden düsseldorf
gegessen habe das jetzt okay leute das
war der erste test und jetzt sind wir
hier auf der apps die gibt es noch nicht
so lange ich weiß die leute ihnen
großstädten wohnen kennen die alle das
ist bei mir jetzt tatsächlich die
premiere dass ich hier bestelle und hier
können wir einfach mal ein geben burger
wir können vielleicht auch so und
schauen wir mal was kommt weiß
düsseldorf ist da wirklich das beste von
denen wo ich jetzt hier bestellen kann
oder was das ding ist halt das ist eine
kette und ich habe schon eine milliarde
mal probiert deswegen wachsmuth da habe
ich auch schon gehört dann lass uns doch
lieber da bestellen wo ist auch ganz
schön teuer die server land mit hier
eigentlich nur einen burger er kommt
nehmen wir einfach dass cheeseburger
lang menü wir haben ja gerade mittag
dann gibt es den landtag jetzt medium
brauchen nur ein platzhalter cecchetti
kostet 9 euro mehr das ist man an sage
ich lasse es einfach so preis dazu und
das wars at once solche checkout wird
jetzt bestellen also die apps gefällt
mir auf jeden fall kümmert eine
bestellung dazu bereit in ankunft um
12.20 super leistung und zu guter letzt
haben wir jetzt noch die app wollt die
ich ebenfalls zum ersten mal testen wir
gehen hier wieder auf burger und schauen
welche hatten die besten bewertung auch
wieder watch wie hat man sogar dann von
0 bis 10 die bewertung und schaue
einfach mal 8,4 geschlossener schade ja
gut dann haben wir schon getestet hut
browser auch noch geschlossen
vorübergehend offline das ist ja super
schade dann kam
karlsplatz 8,8 das ist der beste und
hier bestellen war einfach mal und
klassischen bürger kein bürger ach so
das sind bürger das sind aber ganz
komische burger black athlete
kräuterbutter und mehr sind doch eher
döner oder wieso ist denn food browser
zu kommen ganz ehrlich ich hätte einfach
madonna karlsplatz auch wenn das ein
bisschen komisch aussieht aber warum
eigentlich nicht viele gis sandwich mit
black and flat mit komm her kommt
nebenbei medium rey zur bestellung
hinzufügen und das werde ich jetzt auch
bestellen ist zwar kein
hundertprozentiger bürger aber es geht
ja vielleicht in die richtung erwitter
hierunter burger restaurants gelistet
erstes also schon mal da wo ist der
zweite brite muss zur auflösung was
haben
okay leute ich musste mir kurz einen
zwischen parkplatz suchen ich werde
jetzt einmal testen war noch warm ist
und dann später noch mal ausführlich
berichten ist ja wichtig dass man es
ausprobiert was mich ein bisschen
wundert eigentlich habe ich dabei über
gestellt aber es kann trotzdem wollte
sie haben wir auf jeden fall einmal den
burger
gaildorfer der kommt er richtig lag
direkt mal rein weißen er riecht auch
super leute schaut euch mal diesen
burger an wirklich wild ich hoffe er
schmeckt so gut wie der gestern
leider nicht
das fleisch mit leider überhaupt nicht
frisch das ist immer so richtig
habe ich okay bietet noch mehr dazu so
komme es dabei aber uns die noch mal an
auch ausbaufähig ich weiß der gestern
war wirklich ganz frisch und hat jetzt
lieferzeit aber ein richtig guter bürger
merkt auch noch wenn eine halbe stunde
schon zubereitet ist und der ist weiß
okay aber um welten schlechter als der
gestern jetzt schauen wir uns mal hier
diesen stiller bürger an
[Musik]
nicht zu sauer im auto meist einfach mal
vorsichtig ab genau das war jetzt das
gerät von gold für 12 99
[Musik]
gute qualität muss ich sagen
das ist echt lecker und hoffens
natürlich kein klassischer fahrer ist
gefällt mir der wolke wieder besser als
was über ihn denken also der us bürger
bekommt von mir blieben von zehn sterne
mehr ist nicht drin also ist okay aber
habe schon viel viel besser essen und
der wolfsburger jetzt den würde ich so
liebe mit 82 beurteilen schmeckt frisch
das fleisch ist wirklich gute qualität
aber so richtig umhauen wie zb der
gestern tut es mich nicht
okay leute ich bin zu hause angekommen
und ich habe mir das gerade einfach noch
mal ein bisschen warm gemacht weil ich
finde sachen die qualitativ gut
schmecken auch wenn man sie danach war
macht immer noch top die pommes sind von
watchmi
auf jeden fall solide und besser als der
bürger aber in dieses gerät muss ich
jetzt einfach noch mal reinbeißen und
ist auch aufnehmen
da hast du auf jeden fall eine menge
butter drin aber das ist auch unfassbar
lecker ich habe eben acht mal zwei
gesagt ich glaube ich gehe sogar hoch
auf 8,6
und was war gut leute ich würde sagen
irgendwas mit erfolg das war's mit dem
bartosch aus düsseldorf in zukunft ich
weiß es nicht ich ein richtiger bayer in
zukunft freut auch die ersten videos
können gleich viel und es ist einfach so
dass ich mein ich geb gegen geld für
essen aus dann kann ich auch gleich mit
füllen
das war von mir dran